quiet demon this one's drawing the T
John Moran minutes uneasy Lynbrook AJ
Williams to screen and colors
switch off John on him so Moran takes it
and throws it Murray answers the triple
drop Marcus ended up at a basketball
diamond in the wrong Murray State the
racers were rent drugs the team slips it
into color job
cross it over rockin the cradle and
create for Shaq Buchanon behind for a
cow
mrs. Marin wait patches are 2d draws
five kissed another assessed as heaven
breath four for four from three keep
moving front everybody converges bucket
first day 11 straight wins since
February 2nd for Murray State job around
lips to the corner ease three worried
about who's defending him see right
there that's the rescreen he gets enough
space to get a piece of the paint you
can and onto the screen from koehlers
back into the hands of Java ran trail by
Bailey block a long no screen it's all
job
step back jack
put them on shakedown street he goes
seven-point lead into the half Brendon
Bailey Joe Bereta
look at his footwork to create
separation just too quick with the ball
in his hands my jaw Moran giving him
five rebounds now whip to the head
buchanan in top wants to play he watch
the ball the tournament's two leading
scorers and what a great backdoor cut oh
boy at the rim wow what a great backdoor
cut
Oh guarding marques Howard it's over to
the wing to miss three another rebound
Moran
[Applause]
back in striking distance
Marcus Howard floater in transition
Moran has another rebound and too fast
and John Moran does such a great job of
advance passing eyes up which resulted
in a stop Moran Tron two defenders in
creating again for colored back into the
hands of a rent with Joey Hauser and
Brendon Bailey chasing he does such a
great job of just extending the
double-team and then with his joining
job pay what Brendan Bailey's done as
good a job as you really can't do it is
so impossible look at that feed
do they make their teammates better
would you answer that with a Marcus
Howard 23 points on 27 field goal
attempts
from meringue this performance by
Marantz immediately eyes to the rim all
game market has run the floor hard he
got been hot and marcus howard 23 points
out 27 field goal attempts
from marine grant pushes a handicapped
transition to trips it's a triple for
job rent guarded by Trent force but it's
a team effort for the Seminoles all eyes
on 12 step back socket three for jock
Marais they've left him alone twice and
twice he's made him pay twenty five and
white leads Florida State and scoring
comes up the bench job again three from
the way John race it out to an early
lead for Murray State
for Florida State he's a senior he's
their playmaker is no late game Moran
gets an early screen and drops it off
for Darnell code switching on their ball
screen action step back jump up the
phone may 3 4 job Moran he JC boys the
best 3-point shooter by percentage Moran
behind the screen to game matters at
home jump feeling just fine terrific job
by letter Hamilton and his staff rant
off the curl gets to the rim at a top
finish for John Murray Brown picks it up
brown crossing over get to the corner
jump the red takes it in Komachi look at
the Hang Time 7 4 meet 6-3 at the rim
and that is the months you have to
prepare for the letter Hamilton's team
to the rim a highlight for Gilmore lead
into the hands of color John Moran
touches it again Moran tried to spark
something too late for Murray State all
the way to the rim rajamma ran attacking